the car oh I mentioned to Michael today
that it seems like safety seems to be
the name of the game is there some
psychological aspect being the day
before the rest day that the players
consider you know not wanting to lose
and have to suffer for two more days
before there's another game uh maybe I
mean I think in general it's very
difficult of course because everyone is
so strong here that I mean you don't
really want to take big risks because if
you take a big chance that you make
maybe one or two bad moves you're gonna
lose because people at this level that's
I mean that's just the nature of it so
it's kind of just try and be safe I
guess trying not do anything too insane
and let the game progress and see what
happens from there with Mickey being the
wild card in this tournament did you
have higher expectations perhaps when
the game began uh well certainly not
with black maybe if I the white pieces I
would have wanted a little bit more than
I got in the game but I mean okay you
know Mickey's a very strong player I
mean it's that's like saying you know if
I if I were to play anyone anyone you
know at 2,700 let alone him and expect
to when I mean let's let's be honest you
know Mickey's a very strong player I
think he was number three or four in the
world at one point so I I was just
trying to get a game and I got some
chances but probably never never really
enough did you feel like you were
pressing at any point during the game um
I thought maybe sometime went around
when i played 94 maybe there were some
chances but objectively it didn't really
seem like there was uh was very much
perhaps i could have tried this move
work up seven to play for a five instead
of going 94 um but after I played 94
which I mean it's very committal and
straightforward I think it's probably
slightly better but nothing nothing
special at any rate and tomorrow is not
only the rest day but it's your birthday
do you have big plans for your birthday
tomorrow uh not really I mean I guess
this is the seventh year in a row now
that I've celebrated my birthday here in
London um perhaps a little bit unhappy
that i'm not actually playing tomorrow i
have a very good score when i played on
my birthday here but that being said
it's it's always nice to to be here in
London for my birthday too to celebrate
with with
family and I'll just enjoy it but
there's there are no big plans oh just
go out have a nice dinner and that's
about it well happy birthday from all of
your fans thanks thank you back to you